we've been friends for a while we've
tonight and I met you in 93 I think so
when your show starts singing -
September of 93 yeah yeah cuz I came in
I met you at the Old Town Ale House I
saw go where Roberts Michael introduced
us so you would we were scouting for
talent you said you said to me I do not
like you go away yeah that's right you
go to hell as what I said you go to hell
yeah and then I said I know talent you
don't have it and you'll never make it
in the business exactly right that's
exactly I think forward is what he said
before this all you want okay all you
want an interview is honesty listen if
you didn't go the way you thought it
would with me yelling at you at the end
no but I've also always admired that you
have this a work ethic that I think we
both yes yeah you ever work I think we
yeah we really care about the product
and so we you know I learned so much
from you I don't know if you know this
but I used to write that ambiguously gay
duo cartoons Robert I as I was I am I am
ace Pirellis Gary and I'm ace yeah yeah
hold onto my belt buckle with your teeth
friend of friends exactly we always have
that graphic ready to go so I was I was
over 30 rock when you had the old gig
and I'm in Roberts office at SNL on and
we're typing away on the script like
that and he's got on your show your
rehearsal because he's got to do triumph
that night or Clutch Cargo or something
yeah and you're sitting at your desk and
you've got to be writers sitting here
and you've done some DES piece I can
remember yeah we're probably going
through so you're looking at the cards
like this you've done the DES patient
you go so um what do you guys think of
this and and I stopped because there's
something in your tone of voice I look
at it and they went it's okay it's okay
it's okay and you look like this you
looked at them you went good enough gang
rides again
and I went oh Jesus yeah sweet-and-sour
Jesus was that just agonizing to look at
and I was about three months away from
starting The Colbert Report yeah and and
and and I said I can't that's agonizing
Robert goes what are you gonna do he's
got to say the jokes yeah just got to
make sure you have a good line with it
that's all yeah yeah
terrible terrible you're a terrible
person I'm a terrible person person and
yet Lee not on camera like oh he's like
on Tao oh no when the cameras go off the
stuff says you could never take back the
minute the minute we cut away from this
show tonight I'm diving into the crowd
and just fighting everyone oh yeah
that's a trigger yeah
[Applause]
you